hey guys welcome back the park attacked
the station has been sitting in an empty
grassy Greenland for over a week now and
it's about time that something's done to
change that so in this video I'll be
working on the cue actually add some
scenery and buildings around it a very
small restaurant which is really not
that much but you know it's just a small
something on the side which is on the
rights of the screen at the moment there
will be a pagoda which is actually quite
cool and some foliage in rockwork just
to finish the round itself off now I
wanted to start off with the queue and
actually covered that up for well as one
interesting reason I thought it would be
interesting to have it covered up and
have all sorts of scenery and in the
shape of houses around it instead of
just leaving it you know be a normal
queue that kind of just winds through a
bear forest or a rock work or things
like that since I want to get like an a
Japanese town atmosphere to this area
but it's kind of hard to get that in
without any of the Japanese scenery
items that you'd kind of want to have
there is just no Japanese scenery in the
game yet so no Japanese lanterns or
fences or anything to really get that
atmospheric going in the scenery and so
I thought the next best thing to get it
into the park would just be to you know
have the layouts of the buildings in
there and trying to get the atmosphere
with the buildings as much as I can so
instead of you know having the queue go
through some sort of hum while landscape
that supposed to be Japanese I figured
it would be cool to have it go
underneath a building which is a little
unusual especially for this park because
it's a bit more like like what you would
actually kind of see in real life and
something which I haven't really done in
this park so far in that it doesn't
really work from a park tech perspective
but having a building like this and
actually having the cue zigzag
underneath it is a more of a like
real-life thing if you want to get rid
of some fences open up some ropes or
close up some ropes to make the queue
longer or shorter on well depending on
whether it's really busy or not so busy
day and
from that kind of standpoint I do guess
it kind of works to have this building
over here which the q6 X underneath and
it is also actually surprisingly
functional for the park itself because I
didn't want to be cut off the the end of
the park as much as I can
since the park border is very close to
this here and just leaving it be a
forest kind of felt like it might be
just a weird sort of end to this path so
this you know adds a bit more of like
something a building that's kind of in
the distance and closes off the park
border as you walk toward it and I think
that's quite nice it also helps to get
the layouts of a Japanese theme a bit
more in this general area because I do
want our layouts everything a bit like
it's a Japanese town to at least get the
atmosphere going that's also where the
pagoda and the small restaurant is gonna
come in quite handy which are built in a
second after I'm done with these rocks
you actually see quite a bit of rock
work in this video and some of it is
really the smaller kind of rock work
just placing some smaller rocks to get
some detailing in but quite a bit of it
is also really the large rocks that are
pretty much just used to make the big
cliff facades which you don't really get
in the game because well the way the
terraforming system works obviously but
I did want to get some in to get that
you know Japanese mountain kind of
atmosphere into the park and now this is
the the small restaurant building
restaurant ish kind of thing it's just a
really small one of those corners where
you just get like a bit of food and sit
down on a picnic table or some sort of
table outside only catch is of course
that protects at least vanilla at least
at the moment doesn't have any tables
which makes restaurants in general quite
a bit hard after practically impossible
to get right in vanilla and why I
haven't really been doing it so far and
just pretty much stuck to the stalls but
the problem is that this area here was
quite a bit empty like it's it's a very
long stretched out at your grass which I
didn't want to you know just add trees
to because that just seemed like a waste
space it also seemed like a waste of the
coastal layout like it would just go
through the forest and not really have
any interaction with scenery or parts so
I didn't want to filled in but it's just
way too well narrow for a flat ride to
fit in nicely and it's a bit too big to
just have a random path to kind of just
explore the area so I thought the next
best thing would be to just add a quick
restaurant to it it's nothing big
especially when it comes to more
obviously the size of the building but
also when it comes to the style of it I
really felt it was maybe a bit too small
to actually get a Japanese style into
the building it's well probably very
theme-park Japanese anyway but it's it's
also hard to get you know especially on
a scale like this get the Japanese
elements into the building
the Japanese roofs and shapes that you
commonly see on building so it's more or
less in the colours and on the walls
then I think it did turn out quite okay
but on the shape of the building itself
it's almost like a bit of a mixture
between a Japanese town house and like
one of these bigger villas for the
samurai people that you would see I
don't exactly know the Japanese names
but it's it's a bit of a strange
mishmash of theme park Japanese probably
in the end but um at least I wanted to
get that in here just to have something
going into this area of this part of the
park and it also was a nice way to get
some more scenery into this part since
you know have a small path going over
here was just having a good excuse to
get extra flowers or extra plants and
all sorts of scenery going next to the
park go next to the path which also adds
up to you know more scenery around the
coastal track and just an area that fits
well more nicely together in the end I
think and just to sort of overcome the
lack of picnic tables or tables and
chairs in the game I thought it would be
cool to add like there was very small
squares with benches around it but it
does look a little bit weird I may want
to look at that at some point in the
future I just thought you know it's the
next best thing since we only have
she's in the game at the moment even
though the shop itself is actually not
even functional I definitely need to get
my ex together and actually place a
store in this thing at some point in the
future because I totally forgot about
that so yes at the moment it is not
functional and I was hoping to actually
get a small shop into it so that people
can actually buy some stuff and I don't
know eat or drink something but I
completely forgot about the one thing
that I built this building for I said
that's something you'll see in the
future no need to worry about it but
yeah I just forgot it
I just forgot it at this point in time
the gardening around it is quite
interesting as well one of the reasons
why I wanted to do it in this like
little bit different way than the rest
of the park is you know really to get
those subtle differences in the foliage
in between the different parts like I
obviously don't want to have completely
different foliage because this is still
one park in one physical location but
you know get some very small hints
toward the countries that the areas are
from in every area of the park so here
the foliage is a little bit Japanese
which you kind of start to see right
here with a few more of the red trees
and very small round bushes well I
always found really interesting about
Japanese gardens is like a flowy it
always like there are all sorts of
bushes many of them are really like ball
shaped and they all sort of flow over
the environment it's really hard to
explain it but you know where you kind
of contrast it with European gardening
where European is just like it's all
decoration and it's largest metro and
planned outs and everything is like very
man-made Japanese gardening feels a bit
more natural a bit more like it just
kind of flows with what surrounded which
is pretty cool and which I am not sure
how I can really get that feeling into a
grid game like this but um well at least
I tried there are actually some ways in
which I'll tried a bit more in the
future somebody gave me the really
awesome tip I don't remember who it was
but I definitely want to return to it in
the next episode in which I hope to do
it to lower trees into the ground
and you know use the top of a tree as a
bush which I didn't really know it's
very possible in Park tech but you can
just at least at the moment terraform to
have a small pits than place a tree
inside that pit then raise the land up
again to actually have a lowered tree so
you can actually get some slightly
bigger bushes or bushes with different
textures and it can be quite fun and
useful so that's something that I want
to mess around in the next episode or
maybe some episodes after that and
definitely something that you might want
to mess around with if you're a bit into
foliage as well or if you want to you
know break away a little bit from the
somewhat limited amount of foliage that
we have in the game so far now to
actually catch up with the time-lapse
again at this point I wanted to build
the pagoda which ended up taking quite a
while I think one of the the biggest
challenges with this pagoda is that it
had to look like a pagoda from an
isometric perspective yet at the same
time I did want it to be shaped like a
pagoda which might sound a bit strange
but it basically the issue is that I
obviously needed full tile roofs that
stick out from the building to be like
those square shaped roofs which stick
out from a pagoda but I also wanted the
walls to be visible because know the
balls are gonna give an idea of what the
color scheme of this building is and
that it's actually a pagoda with a tower
in the middle of it and a couple of like
Tests pagodas then I built just to see
how this would work out like the roofs
were too close together and you couldn't
even see the walls because the roof
stick out a full tile and you know the
the height between the floors needs to
be quite high to actually be able to
still see the walls of the tower itself
so there was a bit of a struggle with
getting that height right and then there
was also the issue of getting the
well the textures of the walls
themselves right because I didn't want
to have this this white war with red
would work kind of pagoda which you know
is obviously very heavily inspired by
pretty famous pagoda in Kyoto which I
don't exactly remember the name of and I
suck at pronouncing it but it's
basically very inspired by that just a
red pagoda with some brown roofs to form
a nice centerpiece to this area it's
actually at the crossing two of two
paths that lead into this area and so
it's more or less like a big welcome
sign and the big thing that sort of
towers over the rest of the area just a
big Rini in general basically now I
think this is how I ended up having the
pagoda in the end with I'm not entirely
sure but about six or seven steps
difference in Heights between the roofs
you know just to be able to see each
individual roof well at the same time
also keeping the walls a little bit bare
just enough to see that there are walls
inside and just enough to see as well a
little pattern on the walls though you
barely really see the windows that I put
on there only if you really go out of
the regular isometric perspective and
into you know just straight looking at
it but yeah this is a pagoda nothing
really big though it technically is a
pretty big building but um it does serve
as a pretty nice centerpiece to this
area and I hope it will all bring it
together a little bit more in the future
because as you can see I do have like
some still empty pieces of land around
the pagoda which I want to fill in with
buildings in the future and I'm hoping
that those should tie into the building
of the pagoda quite nicely as well now
the last thing that I wanted to do is
make a small lake around the coast or
well more precisely mine underneath it
and have a mountain right next to it
which is going to be most of the scene
of the roller-coaster what I wanted to
do with the roller-coaster is make sure
that it's quite visible so you can see
it from the path that sort of runs
alongside the water and the enterprise
here
well at the same time I wanted the
coaster to be a terrain conforming
inverts much like you know nemesis black
member and to a little bit of an extent
I still think it's quite a bit like
alpengeist as well and it's those sort
of two things which made me think that
it would be best to have a big mountain
right underneath the lift Hill just so
that the track you can stay quite close
to the ground at all times while at the
same time you know the entire coaster is
going to be visible from the paths where
you can kind of walk around underneath
the coaster and you know so in the end
it'll be a nice terrain conforming ride
for the coaster itself while not being
too you know invisible from the paths I
think I may be a bit of an issue with
some terrain coasters like Bordeaux -
especially at the beginning has like
some very hidden in the trees and the
hills kind of parts of the layouts
nemesis has the same with some parts of
it though it is quite visible and it
goes for black man as well as soon as
you have like something that conforms to
the terrain you can't really stay close
to the paths are very visible at all
times but I didn't want this cause it
would be quite visible and that's why
placing it on this side of this hill
felt like a good way to sort of get that
in and what will hopefully help with
that is going to be the rock work and
sweet Jesus it's gonna be a lot of rock
work it's basically going to fill this
entire side of the hill and it did feel
like a pretty big risk like at the time
I just sort of jumped into it like Yolo
I'm just gonna place rocks all over the
side of this hill and see how it turns
out for the park but there was a bit of
an idea behind it I thought it would be
cool to have some rock work instead of
the the terrain in the game itself since
you know you can't really got any steep
slopes but even though while this isn't
really too steep of a slope I wanted to
have a really steep cliff face right
underneath the lifts able to show to
give you a wall as a background sort of
backdrop to have the coaster run against
yeah you can't really do that with a
train since it's well not very steep and
especially this Hill is almost like a
roller coaster tycoon one hero it's just
a very square ish here with some steps
it's almost like you can have some rice
plantations on the side of it and yeah I
didn't really want to have that sort of
hero I wanted it to be quite rocky quite
steep more like a cliff face than gentle
grassy hill and the only real option to
do that seemed to be to just have a lot
of rock work on top of it so this is
like that really massive rock work to
Sanders sort of sculpt a mountain here
instead of just the smaller details
though at this point I'm getting into
the details as well adding some small
rocks all around this just to you know
make it look a bit more interesting than
just one big collection of huge rocks
until you get some smaller boulders in
down there and they also help to kind of
connect it to the rest of the area I
always like to when I do my rock work
have some smaller books that sort of
scatter around the larger rocks
especially on the bottom of it kind of
like the pebbles that break out of rocks
in real life and that you see kind of
collecting in these streams of sand and
small rocks that you see underneath real
rock facades
and it just all connects it a little bit
more to the sand because having large
rocks and to the sand it kind of
connected more to the grass area around
it because having like really big rocks
right next to grass with no way of a
real transition just very often seems
very like abrupt and very sudden and
like it doesn't really fit together and
glide into each other very smoothly and
I think the small rocks can help quite a
bit with that as well I also like to do
it in this order because you know it's
it's a lot easier if you kind of start
off with sculpting out the general shape
of the rock work that you want to make
with very large rocks first and then get
into the detailing and you know making
the rocks look nice on the outside by
using the smaller rocks to get that bit
of texturing in
most of the time is definitely gonna
stick in making the small rocks and
adding those all around it and it's
quite a bit of a tedious process as well
especially if you're way too
perfectionist and picky like I am
sometimes it like you can sing quite a
bit of time into placing these very
small rocks all around the sides and
having like the the placements of them
just rights but I was quite happy with
how it looks at this point now it did
look like one very big gray blob which
doesn't really mix well into the rest of
the area at this point so adding some
trees to it I thought would help to make
this London a little bit nicer with the
park and make this a little bit less
like one big great barren wasteland of
rock and the trees are falling over
because of heavy gravity of pulse mode
at the moment which does make it a
little harder to they'll get an idea of
what it looks like though I still like
to play on pulse mode I'm not really
sure where that really comes from it's a
bit of a habit actually from other games
which do have a day and night mode at
least vanilla and that's you know you
sort of want to have a certain time of
day but I guess over here I didn't
really want the rain to appear and it
appeared like a little bit ago and I
didn't want to really have to do with
that again is you know you can see
things a little bit more clearly when
it's not raining so I put up with the
very strange-looking trees for well a
couple of times just before going back
to real time for a little bit and have
them actually you know go back into the
position that they should be I do hope
this bug which I also think appeared
quite recently gets fixed at some point
in the future because it is quite
strange even though it can be really
funny as well now I'm obviously talking
about that because this is pretty much
just three placements and it's not that
interesting just kind of standard trees
throwing in a couple of those red
poplars or yeah they're poplars a couple
of those red poplars to get a bit more
of a Japanese vibe to it I thought it
would be nicer to you know get some red
regular trees in maybe some other kind
of colors but it's pretty hard to fit
those in when it comes to you know the
space since they are
large and the poplars are just so easy
to get into all sorts of small spaces
and especially around the rock work here
I didn't want any trees that are half
drowning in the rock work so it was
quite tough to get them into the exact
spaces and I did want to have like most
of the trees just be green pine trees to
get a pine tree forest and look through
this part of the park much like the rest
of the park just to have that fit into
the climate in which this is supposed to
be and even though I have no idea what
the exact climate of this point would be
or where Cydonia Hills us even located
like what kind of country will even call
a theme park Cydonia hills it doesn't
really make any sense
by the way yes I did name it after
Knights of Cydonia it but that's a story
for another time actually because this
time-lapse is ending so maybe we'll have
story time with silver at some time
later but thank you guys for watching
this video and I hope to see you guys
next time